[Music]
in old versus new news suited by
mitsubishi mazda yo chick she drives a
Honda rider Geo say me say checkmate you
say those words yeah we parodied a long
time with it's um it's mercy the way
Kevin M released a surprise album and
the response by Machine Gun Kelly has
gone viral supplies some fries
alright so I'm not gonna play any of
these songs you just gotta listen to the
holiday Goss parent exactly
so Eminem recently came out with a
surprise album called kamikaze have you
guys yeah I heard one song on there I
heard the whole album me too my wife is
obsessed pretty much well she would she
would have loved to be here but she
couldn't but yeah she would have been
perfect for this we could have just all
sat back and I mean she's gonna watch
this video and be like oh y'all [ __ ]
up y'all didn't do it right
she was legitimately pissed when I know
she's known enough she was legitimately
pissed that she couldn't be here for
this one cuz she's like we're finally
get to talk about Eminem I can't even be
there mama yes during one of Eminem's
tracks that's when he disses Machine Gun
Kelly I'll never show you photos this is
everyone though I think you did he did
he did selectable
know what the hell he looks so weird
that's the worst picture ever that's
like a Jewish rapper when I was uh when
I was eight years old and I was a cowboy
for Halloween that's my mom yeah my mom
took the little the little mascara and
made a beard that's what he looks like
yes this is Machine Gun Kelly have you
guys heard of them I heard him a long
time ago I know he's not big out here in
the West Coast but in like Midwest he's
pretty big there's like you know that
like white-trash to Ohio Indiana like
that group like like he's that style
just has a topaz name yeah
machine gun tell you like that after
gangster right it's like a mop mafia guy
or whatever like the time he got in town
hands I'm like that yeah one of those
guys he was yeah classic gangster yeah
him and Capone and all his guys were the
Rat Pack of the mob you know he signed a
bad boy so he signed to a big label
unities label yeah all they use like
mainstream means yeah big that's like
everybody in LA is signed to some label
and you know they're still working at
Karos they do which is great by the way
it's really I like but he's like hip-hop
though and then I it's just interesting
that he was called out because I
consider him to be more so that then
like the new artists that Eminem was
kind of like shooting at so well did
Eminem well I mean it didn't even call
out machine gun until he talked so fast
I didn't hear it he didn't call him out
for like him being an artist he called
him out cuz he like tweeted had his
daughter and called her hottest that but
he also does mention about like so these
are
Eminem's lyrics but next time you don't
gotta use tech 9 if you want to come at
me with the submachine gun I'm talking
to you but you already know who the [ __ ]
you are Kelly I don't use sub limbs and
sure as [ __ ] don't sneak diss but keep
commenting on my daughter Haley that's
those are his lyrics so I guess he like
dubbed him and
tec-9 song yeah so then that's what
Machine Gun Kelly came out with his own
diss track and he titled it rap devil
because in Eminem's
he's the rap God rap God so then he's
calling was the first track of Eminem it
was called um it might be the ringer
yeah yeah yeah yeah number one
personally I only like that track the
most yes a couple of other ones but uh I
don't know I don't know how I feel about
it because I know it was like done real
quick and it's a surprise album so I
can't expect it to have the same level
of musicality and you know like radio
ready music like like a like a finished
album but I mean I kind of love and also
hate it because I know that he can do
better and I don't think that the the
disses and the burns were as good as
what I expect Eminem to do and then but
I like how he's bringing back that like
it just feels like a raw like old-school
mixtape like of like underground hip hop
and like just straight-up tracks of like
pure lyricism and some of them don't
even have hooks like it's not even like
a a song radio song like that it's just
nothing but straight rap how come nobody
mentions that Eminem disses himself all
the [ __ ] time and like almost every
one of his songs look at three tracks on
the album is about Hindman is like
complaining about a girl that he and
it's like man you got problems picking
choosing the wrong women but it's like
him making making fun of himself
constantly does yeah it constantly does
so that's why it's always so
entertaining me when people like I'm so
offended by Eminem like how dare he and
all the [ __ ] I'm like dude he's like rag
on himself better than you can rag on
him like he takes himself out harder
than people who come out him take him
out like it's always like energy is buck
compared to the Rainer yeah I mean
nothing touches Eminem this guy I've
never heard of them
I don't know anything about it maybe you
guys are fans of them I don't know I
thought it was a week he's like just
just comparing lyricism to lyricism and
bars the bars like Eminem's Rainer was
[ __ ] sick as [ __ ] and it was almost
like invincible and it's almost like no
matter what anyone else says just
technique alone you can't touch him he's
just so crazy good like his rhyme
schemes his puns like everything is just
on another level that he's gotten faster
- it's crazy I'm like this cats almost
50 and he's like faster than [ __ ] MGK
Streck had a lot of musicality though
and like you could play it over and over
and enjoy the song whereas like I don't
think there's anything on the album that
I can keep playing over and over it was
like like like it's just a straight diss
track but you know that's the thing is
like that's why I love and hate it at
the same time because it doesn't have
the same level of what I expect from
Eminem well a lot of people are saying
that they're happy that MGK did this
because then they're they're just
anticipating Eminem's rebuttal to that
they're like hell yeah like bring this
out of em like this is that's what I'm
looking forward to and I'm like damn
like I tweeted the other day I was like
do you think Eminem is actually gonna
respond like do you think he's on the
level - give him a dedicated diss track
because the difference is what Eminem
did is just an all-out like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you right and MGK
has a dedicated like diss track so to
get that back he has to feel like he's
on the same level but how sad is it that
people are more excited about Eminem
responding no say because he's just by
it's like so this guy thinks he just
burned Eminem but
everyone only cares that M&M is gonna
respond to him yeah like that's where
it's like dude like it's just so dumb
that's not I don't even see it as beef
it's kind of I see it as it's a teenage
son kind of rebelling against ya there
and and in the track indicate he's
giving props to him and he's like giving
he's giving praise as he's doing the
diss track mean he's always talked about
it though yeah but I mean that's why
it's not pure beef like it's not like
biggie Tupac it's none of that it's just
I think he's he's fishing for response
but what I love about it is you know
these guys are bringing back hip hop
yeah a lot of people are saying I can't
believe Eminem took the bait because
honestly this is like giving Machine Gun
Kelly a lot of player whatever the [ __ ]
and then nobody's ever heard of him
we're all talking about now but he
obviously called out like called out his
interest in Haley oh okay
to spur Eminem yeah I mean give me a
because they're also saying that because
of that tweet of calling Haley hot as
[ __ ] that mm pretty much blacklisted him
from his shade 40 80 45 yeah all the
podcasts coming onto the shows
interviews yeah all of that much
blacklisted Machine Gun Kelly this
happened like in 2012 or season 2014 wow
this race I am it took you like six
years and a surprise out in the
disappear something like that maybe we
get sober a little my first rodeo
even there's Eminem being sober he's
like oh you're 46 and you're sober is
like don't hurt as much as I could like
you're so during bori 6 & 7 keep up
please
because I heard you had a fun boat party
yeah yeah and it's not like on the same
level because there's only like two
lines dedicated to MGK from mmm and then
like I mean MGK had a whole diss track
to go in so we're not looking at it like
apples to apples right now we have to
wait for that response and then we will
see if like you know what's really gonna
happen dude it's like this guy's sitting
on death row just waiting to get taken
into the chair
you know I'm sailing the note to know
that mmm is about to do a diss track
about me I think I would crawl into a
[ __ ] hole somewhere
you know what I mean really you wouldn't
take it as like this weekend around me
personally I would find it funny
obviously but talking like if I'm just
some regular Joe I I would be ready to
to get the tongue lashing of a lifetime
you know I'm saying yeah
just think of it it's almost like
Jeffrey Ross about to roast you yes and
now the whole world has ammunition like
when you go to the supermarket those are
the same lines are gonna repeat to you
when you go to the gym when you go get
your dry cleaners it's like the whole
world not has the the mind of Jeffrey
Ross and ammunition to roll stuff the
[ __ ] out of you you know what though
life before giving but you can tell you
a lot of respect because they're saying
that like no one like out of everyone
that Eminem called out like he's the
only one so far that has responded so
they're like man that was a fast
response to it doesn't take balls of you
if nobody knows who the [ __ ] you are
though I won't agree well in the rap
world he's known he's not like an
absolute nobody yeah just he's not
mainstream like like if you ask you know
if Ryan Seacrest ain't talking about him
right he don't exist what people will be
now like he made a good move because now
yeah now like and people think this is
pretty good because no one has the balls
to really strike back no one has the
ability or skill so I like it and I love
it because what people have been doing
is just subtweeting like [ __ ] like even
in the rap it's so [ __ ] it's they
don't call out names anymore sneak this
in yeah the last biggest one was like
when it was Drake and and that other
dude that weak male yeah me oh me yeah
yeah they're cool yeah but that was that
was like soft somebody said huh someone
needs to die of his real being that was
too far that was too far like in our era
when when people were killing legend
legends can't die let's keep it legends
or not let's keep it hip-hop and not
gangster when people die and legends are
born I like that how about young bucks
Tommy just goes up and shank someone on
stage no cuz it's supposed to be hip-hop
dude you're supposed to battle it out
like that was the point yes instead of
going gangster but then they'd what they
do is they they shanked so they can rap
about yes or no
you like to rap about the evidence
that's like two boxers coming out and
shooting each other like they have to
keep it in the ring but then like you
know how like to [ __ ] he's like he did
[ __ ] faith Evan so he can say I [ __ ]
your [ __ ] you fat [ __ ] let's do
it and then you say that's [ __ ]
that's another one died yeah that
scenario follow Seymour [ __ ] it there
you go
[Music]